[Music]
who was not into pokemon when they were
a kid that passed our generation so like
i think
i think we
were at the at like the beginning
no no so when you're in high school you
don't want to really do pokemon stuff no
way but i think you guys well you're
three years younger yeah
that makes sense yeah yeah so you're in
middle school i thought it was lame just
like when power rangers came out i
thought it was lame as hell and then i
have two younger brothers and they got
into it and i was like
oh it's kind of sick
what are you guys watching yeah that
makes sense what about vr troopers vr
troopers is cool yeah
i like vr troopers better i watch
pokemon but i think the cool thing about
pokemon is the cards plus watching oh
yeah and yu-gi-oh came after pokemon too
and it was like a whole number digimon
and all that i don't even know what
yu-gi-oh and digimon is i think i was in
elementary school if you're like
babysitting nephews or nieces then you
have to get in the pool oh shit's like
hard in high school you're high as [ __ ]
you have no other choice but to watch
pokemon yeah dude the gameboy game was
[ __ ] i know a lot of people got into
pokemon with the pokemon go like my
sister she's like she's i think she's
like 35 36 but when she started when
pokemon go came out she was at the parks
bro she was catching pokemon go was a
cultural phenomenon yeah
yeah me and nikki for like five days we
played that game like non-stop just
jaywalking all over the place yeah being
annoying as hell but everybody was
though it was like it was the hottest
craze i don't know what the tracker dude
as soon as they killed the tracker i
gave no [ __ ] about the game imagine if
them shits were nfts way the [ __ ] back
then oh
you could earn pokemon and sell dude
they got to get on this nft game fast by
the way i don't think it [ __ ] matters
they're like multi-billion dollar
franchise right here like i think they
could give a [ __ ] you know the guy that
created pokemon similar to the jk
rowling story is like he was dead
[ __ ] broke in his apartment right
and all he did was spend time like
making pokemon for like a decade and
then it skyrocketed wow you made all 150
initially no no but it was it was
gradual but it's just a crazy franchise
i don't know if he's still alive maybe
he is but it's a crazy story that's
crazy it's always these like authors
that went through like so much [ __ ] and
then they finally like skyrocket well i
mean obviously even if we weren't into
the tv show everybody knows about the
phenomenon right they can go on with
pokemon collectibles trading cards it's
still a huge thing there's multiple
people that are like hella famous on
tick tock and stuff like that for just
unpackaging pokemon trading cards and
stuff like people have careers on it
pokemon go the video it's an entire
world right charizard shadowless 500gs
holy [ __ ] 500 g's
for the first edition one yeah damn
that's a whole ton of money that's a
that's a house i think gary v and logan
paul single-handedly brought back
pokemon
yeah yeah they're the they're the guys
that they already planned it out too
they bought it early
and then they built the hype around it
they pumped it pumped it
isn't that nuts now we gotta wait for
them to dump it
so we can scoop you know what i'm saying
with our winnings on luna can't wait
well i mean uh you know same thing as
they've always done pokemon has gone
into a major collaboration with oreos
what right and now specific rare pokemon
oreos are selling for thousands of
dollars on ebay it's the cookie the
cookies oh [ __ ] a consumable good
that's so dangerous yeah i mean that's
what they said about the crystal pepsi
but you know what when they sold that
[ __ ] on ebay do you have a bottle yeah
crisco i got a bottle of crystal pepsi
original and a bottle of back to the
future pepsi from the movie when they
released the uh in the 80s take a sip
did you take it sealed and sealed down
you would have a back to the future
you know they brought back crystal pepsi
for for some time i didn't get it but
that used to be my favorite drink dude
you actually liked it when you were a
kid i think you remember what it tasted
no but i remember it being bomb it was
in back to the future no they had a they
had a pepsi can that was futuristic i
remember that yeah i'm doing funniness
so crystal pepsi doesn't taste different
than regular pepsi i don't remember
i had it during the relaunch because i
didn't remember it as a kid but during
the relaunch it just it doesn't even i
don't know if it tastes like pepsi it
just tastes like fizzy water yeah it was
like the lacroix i loved it yeah
but i gotta try it again as an adult
yeah
but also back then i couldn't even
finish a can of coke because it's too
sweet so i remember getting yelled at
because uh in third grade we had like a
[ __ ] root beer float day and then the
teacher was like but if you like other
sodas you could bring your own soda so
of course i had to be different so i
brought the crystal pepsi in and then i
couldn't resist during recess so i drink
it anyways and then so during the float
making time the teacher was like where's
your crystal pepsi and i was like i
drank it
can i have some of the root beer please
please she didn't want to she didn't
want to but she gave it to me
that is the most kid [ __ ] let's get
commercial for crystal pepsi because you
know like once you bring that [ __ ] to
school you see it it's like during the
whole class you're just like oh baby
yeah you heard about that study on kids
they had with the cookie the kids that
immediately ate their cookie ended up
being [ __ ] losers in life and the
kids that were able to hold off ended up
becoming successful so the study was if
you if you could eat your cookie right
now or you can wait till the end of the
day and have two cookies yeah and all
the kids who ate the
yeah
disproved it dude he [ __ ]
he got his pepsi now yeah yeah any
[ __ ] name he was working on a
different skill he was flirting with the
teachers like please give me the root
beer though
i beg for the second cookie after yeah
it's
he was working on his game he didn't
even learn about debt
and he doesn't have any that's why he
doesn't know what it is he never knew
what it was
he knows how to beg everybody to clear
his debt he went to the banker he's
trying to bring it
yeah it's a hard job doing this thing
the legit question the oreo's gonna be
the pokemon so so they literally uh uh
they make um oreos just the way they do
but then they have printings of the
pokemon shut up so it's like [ __ ]
squid games you open that [ __ ]
up and it's a pikachu or something so
the most so the most rare pokemon is
pikachu charizard mew
mew [ __ ] man we all got that i don't
[ __ ] know [ __ ] but so like for
example the mew
is printed on oreo and that's the most
rare oreo how much is that going for
four thousands each oreo uh pack is
randomized so they'll have every random
pokemon but obviously the most rare one
is the wait that's mew that looks like a
char charmander [ __ ] off you turn around
muse more pink than that literally first
of all it's something you're looking at
the side of the package i can't even see
it that is a charmander on the cookie
oh it's on the cookie oh dude my vision
sucks too
oh that song i thought it was the
marshmallow
and then or like the inner cream when
you open it i thought there was going to
be a picture that would be so much work
and when you open it up it's like this
is not a pokemon why isn't it colored
yeah it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] anthony
print like a [ __ ] asian man signature
or something maybe we can reason with
these people who are spending thousands
and just tell them how stupid it is to
buy it apparently on ebay they're going
they're being priced at listings from
anywhere from 50 to 10 000 to a hundred
thousand dollars what are there any like
percentage checks i got some oreos you
guys do they release any rarity counts
on like
i think i think it is based off of the
whatever the rarity count of the actual
pokemon is based upon what's the
tokenomics for this
it's like dodge coin so it's usually
gonna be deadly shrimp
except that's expiration but it's a huge
crazy i guess it's deflationary well and
it's like the cards because the cards
have a problem with minting and [ __ ]
like it can look like [ __ ] get folded
you're creased you should yeah that's
true even worse
your mom could be like ooh cookies and
then she's like eating it that would be
the worst beat the show you're gonna
fight your mom bro after you already
sold it
she's like oh somebody bought it mom no
and then she and then she spits around
like it was a pidgey never mind
did i ever tell you guys about when i
erased the autograph with my thumb how
so in uh when i was in i think second or
third grade my my neighbor across the
street was gonna go to a dodger game and
this was back in the day when i was like
mike piazza and then like jose canseco
like um
that that error charlie robinson yeah
there's a guy named rahul monteci who
was crushed
yeah and after the game we went to the
back because that's where all the
players rolled out in the limos and
people pass over gloves bats whatever i
had a baseball and i passed it over the
fence raul modestly signed it and i just
couldn't believe it now i remember
driving back in the van i was holding
i'm like oh my god
and i touched it to caress it and i just
spit it
and my whole
my whole thumb was just black like
there's a black line and i'm like
[ __ ]
i just couldn't believe like i just
remember like
i don't know if i did but it just i
couldn't even sleep that night i was
just like do you want something so
precious like this
oh my goodness
two stories in a row from the most kid
[ __ ] ever i forged a bo jackson scene
shirt on my baseball
yeah i just looked at it because we were
six like designed it dude what the [ __ ]
how did they know if things were forged
back then because you see i mean the
other kids definitely didn't [ __ ]
know like when people do signatures it's
so [ __ ] up like are they to be able to
say go that's not his signature yeah
it's not jordan i love it when the
idiots do it like the meth heads do it
because it's like a new baseball and it
says willie mays and it's like it's
perfectly done
fresh ink the best
paper yogi berra
can you still do uh what's the name bo
jackson signature yeah but it's not
gonna look like the
it's gonna be very obvious it's not
[Music]
you